اذا شرطه الاخلاق اولى ايطاحات الاحتجاجات
في ايران وربما لاحقا بنود من الدستور
ايضا ايطاحه اعتبرها محتجون الهديه الاولى
لمهسا امين الشاب الكرديه التي اشعلت فتيل
المظاهرات فيما يرى البعض ان هذه الخطوه
تمثل الحد الادنى من مطالب المتظاهرين ففي
محاوله لاحتواء موجه الغضب التي يشهدها
الشارع الايراني منذ اكثر من شهرين ونصف
اعلن المدعي العام الايراني محمد جعفر
منتظري حل ما تسمى بشرطه الاخلاق المتطو-
المتورطه بمقتل مهسامه معتبر بدايه
تنازلات النظام الايراني تحسبا لتفادي
الاسود شملت ايضا مراجعه البرلمان والسلطه
القضائيه للقانون الذي يفرض على النساء
ويفرد عليهن وضع غطاء للراس ودراسه
امكانيه الغاء الزاميه الحجاب الذي يعود
قراره الى العام
وكانت شرطه الاخلاق واسمها بالفارسيه جست
ارشاد اي دوريات الارشاد قد تاسست سنه
2007 ويحق لعناصر هذه الشرطه توجيه
الاتهامات وفرض غرامات او حتى اعتقال من
تعتقد انهن يخالفن القواعد وهو ما فتح
الباب لممارسه الانتهاكات بحق نساء ايران
واخرها بحق مه سامي الامر الذي دفع ببعض
الدول الغربيه بينها الولايات المتحده الى
فرض عقوبات على شرطه الاخلاق الايرانيه
لكن فيما يبدو ان تنازلات النظام الايراني
لن تتوقف عند نقاط الحجاب اذ اعلن الرئيس
الايراني انه من الممكن اعاده النظر ايضا
في مواد بالدستور الايراني